good evening and welcome to the fifth
installment of the CCA lecture series on
the art of biography my name is Shelby
Ripley I'm a junior from convoi Ohio and
I'm studying history and Latin and it is
my privilege to introduce tonight's
speaker Paul Mariani is University
professor of English at Boston College
dr. Mariani earned his MA at Colgate
University and his PhD at the Graduate
Center of the City University of New
York he is the recipient of a Guggenheim
Fellowship and several National
Endowment for the Arts and National
Endowment for the Humanities fellowships
a recipient of the 2009 John CRD award
for lifetime achievement in poetry he
has published seven volumes of poetry
including most recently epitaphs for the
journey he is the author of numerous
books including William Carlos Williams
a new world a naked dream song the life
of John Berryman Gerard Manley Hopkins a
life the broken tower the life of Hart
Crane which was made into a
feature-length film directed by and
starring James Franco and the whole
harmonium the life of Wallace Stevens
please join me in welcoming dr. Paul
Mariani
it's great to be back here I've been
here a lot of times I love this place I
just want to tell you that as his
daughter they gave me the topic what do
we learn from the lives of poets when I
look back over the past half century
studying the lives of poets I find
myself asking why I spent such a large
part of my life
doing what too many will seem like such
an odd occupation what was there that I
kept coming back to I made that flurry
of words and that multitude of presences
what is the fascination the obsession
with it all really and what do I hope to
share with others particularly the
students I have taught over the past
five decades so I have Hillsdale College
to thank for this opportunity and it is
fitting that this school which I have
visited many times over the past thirty
years should hear something of what it
is we can learn from the lives of poets
that is a very good gin I want to thank
you maybe I shouldn't have said that I
guess I began studying the lives of
poets where many of you are today that
is as a college undergraduate because I
needed answers to some very basic
questions about what made certain poems
feed me as nothing else seemed to be
able to do and the truth is I could not
at that point have articulated even to
myself why certain poems fed me the way
ordinary bread and wine could feed me a
communion time all I do know is that we
live in a world where the hidden beauty
of words he's too often commercialized
debased trivialized and taken for
granted I began to understand in those
early years that too often the language
like the complex beauty of the feminine
and the world like the Passaic River in
New Jersey along whose banks are used to
walk as a boy just as William Carlos
Williams physician and poet had likewise
done years earlier it was he who pointed
out in its epoch of America which he
called simply Paterson the underlying
beauty of what that flint-like
degraded city was but as badly as the
beauty around us like that River had
been damaged still there was a beauty
and innocence within it that if we
tended to it and we cared for it could
restore us to health
and that is what poems and the lives of
poets understood can do for us in
restoring the magic to language every
day you use words William saw words were
like the Great Falls at Passaic it's
filthy waters constantly crashing over
your head words from the news in chopped
up columns which appeared and then
reappeared on another page somewhere
else like some black-and-white cubist
painting by Picasso or Juan Gris or
Brock a to ten stories buying each
morning for your attention all at once
as if to say read me read me while this
is still news words on the radio about
the weather about an accident somewhere
or a bombing in a marketplace 10,000
miles away or closer words on the TV
words on your iPhone's bits of
conversation as people pass you on the
walkway words humming in your head that
won't let go lectures discussions in
which only a fragment is remembered and
yet in the matrix of all that language
words to feed yourself to get things
done to make yourself at least partially
understood and then there come those
moments when something in a sentence or
a poem stuns you or comforts or acts as
a momentary stay against confusion as
Robert Frost said or as the poet who
lived just ten miles south of me in
Amherst Massachusetts in another century
put it your thoughts don't have words
every day they come a single time like
signal esoteric sips
of the communion wine which while you
taste so native seems so easy so to be
you cannot comprehend its price there
it's in frequency that's a late poem by
Emily Dickinson and one I only recently
discovered but something about the poem
something about its ballad form and it's
him like phrasing its rhyming second and
fourth lines it's strong to trauma Turin
trimmer to beat older than Chaucer has
stayed with me like rare good news news
that stays news as the young Ezra Pound
once phrased it thoughts wedded to words
the poet shows us so naturally so easily
it seems words so perfectly stitched
together that one takes them for granted
without our fully understanding what the
cost to the poet was who took so much
and took it and put it into a handful of
words you sip the communion wine
Dickinson says and it tastes like wine
and yet what you are drinking in is
Christ himself God who offered himself
at what great cost once and for all for
all humankind the Word made flesh the
word lifting words to a whole new
reality which when those words strike
home change everything for you so that
you are never the same afterwards in the
presence of that reality as the German
poet Rilke said you realize in that
instant that if you were ever going to
fully understand and perhaps do likewise
with words it will mean that you will
have to change your life my father's
parents
were immigrants from northern Italy and
never had much formal schooling but
instead worked on farms in the place
where they were born until they were old
enough to get married my grandmother
working cleaning hotel rooms and then
raising 8:09 children in a New York
apartment while my grandfather found
work paving asphalt in the city day
after day and on the other side my
maternal grandfather a Russian polish
extraction during the u.s. cavalry
as soon as he was old enough and fought
in the 1916 Mexican expedition against
Pancho Villa and that in France in 1918
where he was gassed though he managed to
hang on for another 14 years if he
learned anything after grade school he
learned it with a carbine mounted on a
horse named red and as for my mother's
mother one of eight whose parents with
Lutheran's from Sweden she made it to
the 6th grade before she liked her
father and most of her siblings began
working in the Patterson mills and the
next generation fared little better
thanks to the Great Depression for my
parents had to drop out of school after
the ninth grade to work
we know the story where it has been
repeated a billion times over but my
mother married at 16 was going to do all
she couldn't have power and wiles to see
that her oldest son went to college and
like my six younger siblings I did I
went to shaman on high school I entered
the seminary for a year I took a fifth
year in the local high school back in
Mineola to learn physics and math and
then went on to Manhattan College in the
Bronx mostly because it was one of the
few choices I really had and because
they would have me and though my father
hoped I would do something practical
like become a lawyer
or CPA or an engineer I fell in love
with literature from the very first day
I entered college and in my typical
last-minute way switched from psychology
to philosophy and finally to English
where in my senior year I discovered the
poetry of Gerard Manley Hopkins a
Victorian English Jesuit whose poetry
was like nothing I had ever experienced
and who captured my imagination from the
day I first read him there were personal
reasons for this as there are for every
one who falls in love with a magic of
words through arts magic as the French
philosopher Raisa Merritt and once
phrased it speaking of the painter Marc
Chagall and through the liberation of
his internal world Hopkins managed to
create forms signifying a spiritual
universe entirely his own while grounded
in his reading of the romantics and John
Ruskin and Thomas Aquinas and Duns
Scotus and for someone like myself whose
father was an auto mechanic who could
fix just about anything and his mother
became a nurse after the older children
could take care of the younger ones it
was a blessing to discover amidst the
gritty sediments of that world a poet
who took his Catholic Christian identity
seriously and whose sang of it in a
language like no other poet I had ever
heard and that to put it simply changed
my life in ways I never expected fast
forward another seven years when I was
married with three small children of my
own and teaching rhetoric and core
courses at the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst when at 29 I
managed to publish my first book it
turned out almost in spite of myself
to be a commentary on the poetry of
Hopkins a day does not go by that I do
not think of him almost as a talisman or
a rabbit's foot of his sort so that
nearly forty years later I published
another book on the same poet this time
a biography that attempted to show how
the poems came out of the life he lived
as a Jesuit priest who probably had more
difficult assignments than any of us I
hope we'll ever have to undertake and
most of them from the outside ending in
what looked like failures really I think
the only thing that kept the priest
going was the sense that he was doing
what he thought Christ his master had
done before him working with the poor
the neglected the marginalized
blacksmith and chambermaids and for the
most part marginalized Irish students in
Dublin and had he lived into his 50s
instead of dying of typhoid in Dublin at
the age of 44 one of his students would
have been the young Irishman James Joyce
let me read one of Hopkins's poems for
you and perhaps you'll begin to
understand something of why this poet
matters so much it's in the traditional
form the Italian sonnet but it sounds
like no other sonnet ever written before
him he was 32 when he wrote it and he
was studying theology with other Jesuits
in the hill country of North Wales the
poem is dated for us May 30th 1877 and
it's called the wind hover and Hopkins
dedicated it to Christ our Lord his Lord
if say the only one I caught this
morning the poem begins I caught this
morning morning's minion kingdom of
daylight's dauphin
dapple dawn drawn falcon in his riding
of the rolling level underneath him
steady air and striding hi there how he
rung upon the rate of a whimpering wing
in his ecstasy then off off forth on
swing as a skates he'll sweep smooth and
a bulb in the hurl and gliding rebuffed
the big wind my heart in hiding stirred
for a bird the achieve of the mastery of
the thing brute beauty and valor and Act
OH air pride plume here buckle and the
fire that breaks from me then a billion
times tolls lovelier more dangerous so
my shovel yeah no wonder of it
sheer plod makes plow down silly and
shine and blue bleak embers are my dear
for call themselves and gasps gold
vermilion how many times over the years
have I read and revisited and taught
this Paul I taught it to students at
Hunter College I taught it to police
officers of the John Jay College of
Criminal Justice including Frank Serpico
who was all mine and for thirty years
and more I taught it over and over at
the University of Massachusetts and then
for the past 16 years at Boston College
I have taught it in Bavaria Dublin
Oxford Toronto Los Angeles New York
Boston Atlanta Orvieto and Key West I
will read it in Jerusalem in May and I
have taught it here at Hillsdale several
times over the past 20 years and still
the poem never grows old for me in fact
it has had just the opposite effect on
me
and let me try and explain by first
saying something of the poem from the
perspective of a biographer a poet and
as a pilgrim in search of gold and gold
Vermillion May 30th 1877 a Wednesday
gerard hopkins who had been at the head
of his class at oxford university
eleven years earlier is now studying at
the jesuit the alligatored st. by nose
near st. Asaph in north wales he is in
his last months of preparation for the
priesthood if he is too independent in
his thinking as far as this theology
exams are concerned deciding to counter
some of the dominican aquinas teachings
with those of the scots Franciscan Duns
Scotus so that he will be bypassed for a
fourth year to study theology and will
instead be sent to teach high school
lads at Stonyhurst still there is this
he has already composed as great ode the
record the deutschland though it has
already been rejected by his Jesuit
editors of the month and he is also
composed half a dozen poems that very
spring poems that have since been read
and studied by hundreds of thousands of
readers in hosts of languages classics
like God's grandeur and as kingfishers
catch fire on a hillock out in the shape
in the sheep fields several hundred
yards from the main building there sits
a small stone Chapel it is to this
sacred space that the young Jesuits come
each may to participate in Mass before
returning to the main buildings where
they will breakfast and then begin
classes for the day and because may 30th
is also an optional memorial
commemorating the French martyr Joan of
Arc and because Hopkins has a special
place in his heart for women Saints like
Our Lady and Saint Steckler and Winifred
and those five nuns who perished in that
winter storm aboard the shipwrecked SS
Deutschland 18 months earlier when
Hopkins was beginning his studies here
at st. by knows st. Jones's example
seems to be very much on Hopkins's mind
this morning and the French borrowings
of a sonnet seemed to indicate this
words like minion and Chevalier and
Cillian and gold vermilion the very
colours of the Royal French flag Joan
carries on horseback in a 1505
manuscript but more as the poet treks
across the open field single filed for
the chapel with the other priests in
formation all in their uniform stark
black soutine's
the poet's eye catches a wind hover a
small Falcon veering an arcing with what
seems incredible freedom and abandoned
and the windswept air about them as if
it were riding the very air currents
turning easily like an expert skater on
the bow of a frozen river how describe
what he sees yes he might have said what
most of us would have said something
like saw a hawk up there in the skies
this morning but what he says is this
that his eye and heart have had in
stressed upon them the very enscape of
the bird and something more morning's
minion kingdom of daylight's dauphin in
this dapple dawn throne falconer the
minion the darling of morning the king
the ruler of Earth's Dominion the door
fan of the kingdom where daylight reigns
yes heraldic falcon as if drawn to the
light the dappled light with its rainbow
of colors yellow orange vermilion but no
to the figure drawn or etched out by the
light itself a figure with its wings
extended like like what
that is the riddle and the emblem and
the Epiphany all in one even if at first
the eye does not see it
a figure edged out against the heavens
like the crucified risen Christ
emblazoned against the Morning Sun but a
figure in action
a verb a verb um if you will the doing
be of the thing writing that is ruling
the world in his ecstasy and the forces
that would crush it break it rebuffed by
that splendid creature as it glides
effortlessly to the winds giant forces
like those that destroy the Deutschland
and would as easily break us ah to have
that power the power to play the
screaming winds as Christ play them and
tame them on the Sea of Galilee when the
disciples cried out in fear for their
lives and when their boat seemed in
danger of going down and yet there is
the paradox that is when the figure the
Falcon buckles and breaks falling
downward as Christ did on a cross
emptying himself for humankind in the
great kenosis that's something like a
fire broke from him something which
turned out to be a billion times told
lovelier and more dangerous and so he
salutes the figure of his master caught
in the hawk his Chevalier who went
before us went just about everyone and I
they betrayed or abandoned the man in
his final suffering but really Hopkins
adds isn't this God's way no wonder of
it consider the way for example clods of
Earth seeded with tiny pieces of Cillian
diamond like shards of quartz say or how
when they are broken and turned over by
the Harrow in the time of sowing will
suddenly shine and flame out in the
morning
or to take another humble experience the
way chunks of seemingly dead burnt-out
coal will slip through the grating in a
fireplace and as those blue bleak embers
like the poet himself in his blue bleak
soutane as they fall breaking through
the grade will gall themselves will
suddenly in that final gesture of
self-emptying revealed an inner fire
which seems to reflect the source of all
fire the creator himself gold vermilion
end the ransom Christ paid the billions
and the billions of gold as it were for
the poet's Redemption as for all of us
the price of love buying us back with
his own life and then there is the
question by composing the win hover what
was Hopkins signing onto for no serious
poet writes lines like these without
being summoned to offer his or her own
life's blood fathering a poem is like
fathering a child there's a lifelong
commitment attached to that initial
ecstasy for Hopkins as safe with John
Donne or George urban or for Emily
Dickinson or Denis levitoff or for that
matter Sylvia Plath the poem is a
mapping an act of the mind an epitaph
another marker in life's journey whether
ascending or descending the wind hover
after all is a fiat assigning onto
Christ's life with one's own without
knowing as Mary did not know when she
gave her fear where that would lead the
joys the sorrows the glories of it all
and so with young father Hopkins
assigned by his superiors to preach in
London than in the working-class suburb
is vark
screwed in a world quite different from
what he had experienced as an
undergraduate at bay lleol where he
graduated at the top of his class for
now except occasionally his world was
not among Oxford Dawn's and Oxford
undergraduates he was being sent instead
to preach and work with the Catholic
working class mostly Irish there as
later in Bedford Lee and Liverpool in
such industrial towns before being sent
to teach undergraduates at Stonyhurst
and then in 1884 across the Irish Sea to
a Dublin that was not happy to have him
and where he would die five years on of
typhoid one more victim of England's
unbeknown neglect of all things Irish
life then Christ's life as failure or is
ultimate victory and that is where the
writing of a poet's life comes in no
question about it we all remain in some
sense strangers to each other call it
the existential unknowability of the
other whether that other is a parent or
a child or a spouse or a lifelong friend
in some sense isn't it true that we
remain strangers even to ourselves so
that our relationship to God to Christ
through our human imaginations may be
the closest relationship we can ever
have certainly there are aspects of
theology in a poetry itself to support
this idea men go by me Hopkins wrote
just months after composing the wind
hover in a much darker vein men go by me
whom either Beauty bright in mould or
mind or what not else makes rare they
rain against our much thickened marsh
air rich beams to death or if distance
buys them twice
death or distance soon consumes them
wined what most I may I after be in at
the end I cannot and out of sight is out
of mind
Christ Minds Christ's interest
what to avow or amend their eyes them
heart wants care haunts foot follows
kind their ransom their rescue and first
fast last friend so even in his darkest
moments Hopkins had something he could
hold on to a little more gin and I'll be
right back
that's one of the things you learn when
you spend your years writing the lives
of others even the lives of poets who
have given us their life's deepest
stories in a language which we are left
to translate into the blood and wine of
something graspable and yet ultimately
beyond our grasp in another month my
sixth and probably last biography the
whole harmonium the life of Wallace
Stevens will be published by Simon &
Schuster professor John Serio who has
spent a lifetime reading and editing
Stevens kindly sent me a copy of a
review he wrote for the book and which
to my own surprise captures something of
what I have tried to do in each of my
biographies 25 years ago when a second
edition of my biography of William
Carlos Williams was coming out I
composed a poem dedicated to Williams
which I called some sort of answer it's
dark again it's 3 a.m. and the only
light the poet biographer can see is the
light leaking from his refrigerator and
of course
he surprised to discover that the
stranger rummaging through the
refrigerator which has morphed into the
one of those old ice boxes is none other
than Doc Williams himself looking for
some plums so cold in so delicious to
eat and finally having caught up with
the poet
I have spent 10 years researching I
asked him point-blank about the life I
gave him well
did I do it did you recognize yourself
and what I said as always seems to
happen when I have finished a biography
the poet's ghost will appear in a dream
to tell me how I did
Berryman did this even shoving Robert
Lowell aside and telling me to do him
first and then he could do low true
years later I remember how the figure of
Robert Lowell appeared surrounded by his
friends and smiled in recognition and
how many times Hopkins has appeared to
me a figure of consolation a friend as
it were an attorney with me or Hart
Crane walking across the Brooklyn Bridge
a compound for me to ghost greeting me
but this time it was Williams you
dredged up several selves I'll give you
credit the doctor poet tells me and in
spite of the darkness that surrounds us
both he assures me that he too was
always one for celebrating light and
then through those glasses of his he
looks directly at me and corrects me and
that New Jersey idiom of his so you're
still not finished with that scalpel you
want to go on probing for the heart and
brain and what good will that do us
listen to a story swift foot Hermes
rises to the surface like a salmon
breaking water
he holds a letter penned in hell you
read it
and you think you understand and you put
your heart at ease before he Yanks the
letter back to hell
so one has told the truth whatever that
may be but always in such figures as we
alone will understand and then it's back
and forth between the poet and his
biographer before the poet tells the
biographer that only in our poems are we
ever really us it's an answer of sorts
then reminding the biographer that try
as he or she may what we write remains
at the deepest level a fiction as it
must for the life itself we'll always
manage to slip away the words of the
poem the words of the biography all
finally a dreamlike world in which we
are surrounded by the amniotic ink of
language sound and a music of sorts
still the biographer tries one more time
and seeing what he thinks is his chance
he lunges in desperation at the ghost as
if to hold him but the biographer has to
admit he was still too quick for me with
one swift move he shut the icebox door
returning each of us to his old familiar
darkness like wallace stevens 'as angel
of reality then quickly too quickly
the poet you have pursued shimmers in
the fading light and like dante reaching
out to embrace the dead poet is gone
such a poem might someday be written by
Mariani about the whole harmonium Serio
astutely notes and the hard questions
posed by the reader giving voice to the
poet does this life you have labored for
so long over expressed the life and
character of a man who was unusually
reticent publicity-shy private complex
as the biographers have been able to
plumb the depths of Stevens's poems to
reveal the living man beneath has he
been able to glean from Stevens's
voluminous clothes journals in his
notebooks as thousands of letters and
essays and published interviews and
preface 'as and acceptance speeches as
well as observations by others a genuine
sense of the man himself and yes does
one get a sense of stevens as a person
and yet and yet for did not Stevens
himself admit that his work like the
work of all artists was finally
autobiographical in spite of every
subterfuge since it cannot be otherwise
there are serial concedes frequent
moments when by blending paraphrase and
quotation the biographer seems to slip
into and under Stephens of skin and we
feel as if Stevens himself is speaking
directly and personally to us but then
it's 3:00 a.m. and the icebox light is
on again and it's Wallace Stevens this
time and he's looking for a dish of
peaches from Russia or two pears or some
Belgian grapes and then Connolly Serio
imagines the biographer addressing the
compound for me the ghost once more
well did I do it did you recognize
yourself and what I said he imagines and
Stephens answers you evoked several
selves you evoke the lover the believer
and the poet I'll give you credit and
you gave a thorough analysis and we both
know how high that highest candle lights
the dark and then the biographer reaches
out to touch Stevens as well to see if
he is real but he was still too quick
for me and like the angel of reality
quickly too quickly
he too like the others is gone so there
it is the quicken life
Hermes that messenger from the
underworld of the subconscious the dream
world the world within the shadows
swimming to the surface of consciousness
once more
mercurial shimmering something luminous
realized for a moment in the reading of
the passage and then the figure is gone
the dream state fractures and the
quotidian light of reality enters our
world again and so it has been with the
years I spent writing the life of
Williams and then on to John Berryman
and then on to Lowell and then that
roaring boy Hart Crane whose story the
actor James Franco turned into a
black-and-white film like the chaplain
chaplain asked silent movies of cranes
own time and then a long 30-day retreat
with the Jesuits and with Hopkins and
then back again in the Great Wheel of
Time to Hopkins whose life and poems
have so shaped mine and then on to one
of the great enigmatic voices of the
20th century Wallace Stevens and then
the candle flickering as it will so what
can I leave you with as the icebox shuts
what can we learn from the lives of
poets first of all that the pursuit of
poetry the quest for a living language
and a quest for something which will
sustain or kill if you let it and will
cost not less than everything it's not a
matter of dabbling any more than just
wishing to run a marathon means you will
ever run a marathon or be a worthwhile
artist or musician or scientist a lawyer
or a doctor a nurse or teacher as
soldier or priest because you fantasize
about such things
what can a study of a poet's life teach
us and what will the bill come to
in the economy of things the poet's
world of the necessity the world of the
imagination the world of words but words
finally which are able to move us as
much as anything can only the
imagination finally is real Williams and
Stevens and Berryman and Laurel and Hart
Crane insist and only God and the
imagination
finally matter as father Hopkins added
to the symposium of voices even if he
had to win through by sir surrendering
everything into God's hands while he
could and while there was still time to
say yes even if it meant going
underground as he did for thirty years
before the last lights of the black West
went and mourning at the brown brink
Eastwood sprang because he believed that
a poet creator even greater than himself
was at work all that time a presence
like the Rising Sun brooding the way a
mother dove will over the bent world
with warm breasts and with our bright
wings some biographers of poets will
want to write about the sex in the booze
and the constant comic collapse of the
poet believing that it is the salacious
in the erotic and that haphazard which
charges their subject and there is no
doubt something to looking at things
that way if TV soap operas are any
indication take my collaborator
collaborator on the Hart Crane James
Franco again for the moment Franco is a
serious man and a poet himself as well
as an actor a producer a director among
so many other things and when he sought
me out to make a film of that roaring
boy Hart Crane after he read read my
biography of Crane the broken tower and
we were walking across the Brooklyn
Bridge discussing cranes life I remember
telling him while he asked me about the
gay bars down at the Brooklyn Navy
how many times Crane tried to take his
own life by falling from a great height
or to look up I told him it's I said
look up at the quiring strings of the
bridge through which the wind was
singing and poet that he is
he listened enough that in the middle of
the film he produced a film noir with
its stock grays and whites and blacks he
interposed a scene where after walking
aimlessly around the streets of Paris
for days and weeks Hart Crane walks down
the main aisle of the Cathedral of Notre
Dom and for one minute the film morphs
into bright color while we hear the
choir extrange of Dona Nobis Pacem
surround us grant us peace O Lord Oh
grant us peace somewhere in his movie
studios Franco has about six hours of
film with him reading one of John
Berryman stream songs and then me
reading one and commenting on it and
being James Franco he had hoped to get
through all seventy-seven dream songs
but though he went from 9:00 in the
morning until 4:30 in the afternoon with
time enough for a quick sandwich in a
soda and that hotel suite down in Soho
in New York with two British cameraman
filming the two of us exhaustion had set
in and it was time to call it quits I
think we got to about 65 of those poems
for Franco is nothing if not
indefatigable and then I said goodbye
and drove the 200 miles from lower
Manhattan back to Western Massachusetts
well I ever see that film again will he
ever direct a film based on the life of
John Berryman I doubt it
still it was a pleasure to be able to
work with him on one of the 20th
century's most original poets both comic
and tragic at the same time what was i
working on now James asked me as I was
leaving the life of Wallace Stevens I
told
we both knew would that meant a 180
degree turn about for Stevens is a poet
the direct opposite of that roaring boy
Hart Crane Wallace Stevens lawyer
vice-president at the Hartford indemnity
insurance company as this specialist in
surety claims who worked and lived in
Hartford from 1916 until his death forty
years on a very private poet this
Stephens author of such classics as the
snowman and the emperor of ice-cream and
Sunday morning as well as long poems
like the comedian as the letter C and
the Aurora's of autumn each of whose
poems demand a great deal of care and
attention and whom Hart Crane himself
recognized as one of the most
distinctive voices in modern ecology
well Franklin smiled there was a poet he
was never going to turn into a film and
many other critics have echoed his
sentiments yes there was Stevens's
fistfight with Hemingway twenty years as
jr. and is drinking down in Key West and
is returning to Hartford with his right
arm still Oh miss Lang having broken it
against Hemingway's jaw but was that
enough compared to the antics of crane
and Berryman the poet MODY Pierrot the
poet has crucified Christ and clown if
you will that was what most people
wanted to make the poet a caged clown so
that they didn't have to waste their
time listening to him or her which was
of course exactly the challenge I knew I
was taking on to show that a man a large
man of Pennsylvania Dutch extraction 6:1
240 pounds who composed his poems as he
took his daily humdrum quotidian
40-minute two-mile walk from one
one-eighth westerly terrorists eastward
to his posh insurance office on the
ground floor of the palatial Hartford
diminutive building at 690 Asylum Avenue
and you try to catch him in the very act
of composing as he suddenly stops and
takes a step or two backward jotting
something down on a pad and then moving
forward again call the roller of big
cigars the muscular one and bid him whip
in kitchen cups can keep us in curds or
on the threshold of heaven the figures
in the street become the figures of
heaven the majestic movement of men
growing small in the distances of space
singing with smaller and still smaller
sound unintelligible absolution and an
end that a dum da dum tum tum to get the
rhythm right and he continues to walk
the Elm lined Avenue the gates of heaven
open into a land where all birds sing
and that biographer and the poet in the
biographer try to hear what the poet is
humming to himself and you think if only
I can find the right words
well I to glimpse the angel of reality
flashing into view before we quickly too
quickly disappears thank you
dr. Mariani has agreed to sign copies of
his book William Carlos Williams a new
world naked in the Philips lobby
immediately following this session we
now have time for a few questions please
stand and the microphone will be brought
to you
I thank you for your speech it's very
good I was wondering how you choose
which poets to write about and to read
Hopkins and William Carlos Williams
seemed pretty different to me in a lot
of ways but what is it about both of
them and others that attracts you and
how do you decide thank you for the
question you you will hurt it yes why do
I choose the poets that I choose I think
I've kind of made it clear why I needed
Hopkins in the beginning right I think
that's that's clear and I think even
with William Carlos Williams the fact
that my mother's family was from New
Jersey and that he had taken the risk of
taking the American idiom and making
that the poetry of our country okay that
meant a lot to me I mean if you place
say the the language of William Carlos
Williams against a TS Eliot or Ezra
Pound or any number of other poets the
Victorians and you find him What did he
say he was once asked by a British
professor in a symposium like this
professor said to him and where did you
get your language dr. Williams meaning
aren't you really what is this American
idiom stuff you're in it you're an
Englishman you know you speak English
and Williams answered he said I get my
language out of the mouths of polish
mothers they're very good at very good
answer he was a he was a doctor who
delivered 2,000 babies okay in the
Rutherford area and what he would do is
he would a patient would come in and
she'd complete you know say look I've
got these problems with the baby
etcetera etcetera and he'd say okay take
this prescription etc and then she'd
leave the room and he would flip up this
typewriter that he had underneath his
desk and he would write down just what
she had said in the exact language that
she had used it he wanted to get that
music you see into his ear and that's
been very important to me I why am i
reading I'm reading these poems because
I'm you know why am i reading these
biographies because I want to be a poet
okay I've published seven volumes of
poetry also when I started out it wasn't
you couldn't find too many MFA programs
so I thought okay
I'll study the poets I'll study them
carefully I'll go to the manuscripts at
Yale and Harvard in Texas etc and I'll
look at the actual manuscripts you can
see where he crossed this out or she you
know etc and I'll learn from that and
I'll keep learning from that so each of
the poets that I chose Hopkins and
Williams and then Berryman why bear even
because he's such a zany crazy guy okay
but he's also brilliant he was a
brilliant professor at the University of
Minnesota okay Minneapolis and but he
also had his problems he drank a lot
okay
he was a womanizer okay and then late in
life what does he do he he's been
studying you know all the Yeats and
frost and said it and he comes down
Hopkins and something about Hopkins and
about the example of Hopkins just just
gets to him see he had lost very manners
losses but his father had killed himself
when he was 11 years old and he never
forgave God he'd been raised as a
Catholic out in Oklahoma and he used to
be an altar boy at the six o'clock mass
when they were about maybe four people
in the pews and and he really loved it
with a father Boniface but once his
father had died he couldn't forgive God
for years he couldn't he kept he was
obsessed with God he kept coming back to
him and it was only at the end when he
was finally locked up it you know in a
locked Ward because he was so drunk okay
that there was a there was a an
Episcopal priest who was in charge of
the group and he said to him John you're
not leaving to teach your class because
every time you leave here to teach your
class you get in a taxicab you teach and
then you tell the taxi driver to stop at
a bar just so you can refresh yourself
before you come back but you know
detoxification and it's not how it works
so Berryman who broke down he said I
need to teach every was the last piece
of you know honor that he had and then
he said no you're not gonna do it he
said but I'll tell you what he said
I will teach your classes for you you're
teaching the Bible you're teaching the
humanities I will teach your classes for
you and he did and something hit
Berryman I mean like wait a minute there
is there is a sense of rescue someone
cares I mean he had never had this
before like this you see what I mean so
he went try for 11 months he wrote some
of the most incredible religious poetry
of the 20th century but the alcohol was
too deep after 11 months he picked up
another bottle of whiskey and he jumped
off the bridge into the Mississippi
about two weeks before he did that he he
wrote a poem though in which he said if
I should fall from a great height Lord
may your Angels lift me okay so even
then it was very much you know on his
mind so what you can see was trying
desperately in the modern times to
follow an earlier model of Hopkins
Laurel because well I'll tell you why
because he had started out he had he had
written some of the great Catholic
poetry he had been out he had been a
convert and he had two Catholicism in
the early 40s during the war and then he
had become a conscience of the objector
and they had he had been in prison for a
year okay and he wrote quicker gravy on
a Nantucket and he wrote some other
extraordinary poems but it was too much
for him he suffered from depression
manic depression and so he left Hopkins
Hopkins was very important to him too
and he went for Baudelaire instead a
different model altogether you see
although he kept kind of you could see
him coming back but you know he was
over-the-line who else
Hoppa then Hart Crane I had to do the
roaring boy I told myself for 20 years I
was going to do you know as wild as he
is Hart Crane is writing some of the
most extraordinary religious poetry
including the Ave Maria section of the
bridge you know he's done it just I'm
gonna know I'm going on but at the last
year of his life
he's down in Mexico City okay Hart Crane
he's 32 years old and he was gay but he
has his first heterosexual and only
heterosexual affair with the the wife of
a friend okay was not divorced okay and
he goes to the great Cathedral in Mexico
City where Our Lady of Guadalupe is and
he can't be is stunned by the Mexican
peasants you know who were who on their
knees are going up the steps you know
and then praying and he begins to weep
and he sends Peggy Peggy Callie the
woman he's having the affair with uh he
sends her a card of the Lady of
Guadalupe and he says not here's a woman
here's a woman so you know you'll find
these if you look deep enough you find
is a searching there so this happened oh
you know all the way through every one
of the uh Oh Wallace Stevens what he
call himself he was he was raised in
Reading Pennsylvania he called himself a
I tried up presbyterian that's what he
called himself
okay he he had there are pictures of him
is you know as a choir boy singing in
the Lutheran Church in Redding and then
you've got then the Episcopal you know
the Episcopal Church down the street and
Presbyterian too and and then he leaves
it all he just leaves it all behind he's
gonna go modern really modern okay and
he waits some of those very very dark
poems like the Snowman and the Emperor
of ice cream etc but as he gets older
you find him moving back looking for
something bigger than himself one of the
things he loved to do there's a church
in New York City called Saint Patrick's
Cathedral it's a huge Church okay he
used to like to go in there whenever he
could okay and just sit in the you know
not while anything was you know no mass
or anything but just to sit there and
meditate and towards the end of his life
apparently he asked the priest he said
I'd like to receive the sacraments now
that I might you know he was dying and
the critics and scholars are they don't
want to believe it they don't want to
believe that their man
did this they would succumb to this but
I've got the evidence so so I make the
case for it you know in the year Wallace
T I'll probably be hung and the next
month is so but there it is I mean I
make my I make my case even Stephens at
the end returns to a sense of faith yeah
and in the poetry as well yeah okay I'm
sorry I didn't mean to go on that long
but there we go
yeah okay thank you for the lecture that
was great my question is the flip side
of the one I was presented at the very
beginning you've done a memoir as well
30 days my question is what do we learn
from recording our own lives and
autobiography no what do we learn from
according our own lives and
autobiography and set up the lives of
others
do you want me to use this so what am i
learning in terms of my own life okay
you know how does it come back on me and
I think it's come back on me in profound
ways when you mentioned 30 days you know
this this spiritual memoir that I wrote
back in 2000 in which I went on retreat
a silent retreat with the Jesuits in
Gloucester Massachusetts back in the
winter of 2000 and part of the reason I
did I got I have three sons and the
oldest one is a Jesuit priest okay and
he teaches Chinese history Chinese
related 20th century Chinese religious
history at Santa Clara
okay that's his specialty so and I've
always had this but since Hopkins when
my oldest boy who's 50 now when he was a
baby
I would read the record the deutschland
to him when he was in his cradle and he
was and I I wonder if I did the right
thing you know because because he went
on to become a Jesuit priest you know I
did think I didn't see that in the mix
you know anyway this is all very
important I'm still in all my own poetry
saying okay here's where this poet was
this boat was where am I and one of the
things I think I'm learning now is just
a sense of I'm not in control of it I'm
not in control of it you know that that
whatever you know whatever is look when
I'm gone okay I'm 75 will be 76 at the
end of the month okay when I'm gone
what's going to be left behind and I
have no way of knowing I
no way of knowing so I have to give it
over I have to give it over to God okay
I wrote a poem called Sam for the lost
and it ends with an image of I take all
my grandkids five of them and my sons
and my daughters-in-law we go down to
the Cape Cod for weekend every year they
seriously build these huge sand castles
I mean they're beautiful you know I mean
they they should be in museums okay
they're that beautiful
but of course what's gonna it's like in
Zen and Zen Buddhism what's gonna happen
within 12 hours the tide will come in
slowly and they'll just wipe it out
completely right it'll be gone okay but
I learned the lesson from watching all
the pleasure and the delight they take
in creating something and then it's out
of their hands after that and I say well
I hope that one of the lessons I can
learn for myself just let it go and if
there's anything of worth there it'll be
picked up if not good it'll be that's
what Hopkins said to let it go see it's
not a it's no longer about me you know
what I mean it's about something beyond
me yeah